bonjour francis carroll bonjour à toutes
et à tous conseiller territorial
exécutif en charge des affaires sociales
et sanitaires
on va commencer par vous interroger sur
le devenir de certaines associations
on entend des présidents d'associations
qui se plaignent de ne pas avoir encore
reçu ou que ça tarde
vous savez les parts de la collectivité
territoriale concernant les contrats
aidés l'état à verser sa quote-part de
75%
il ya une partie qui doit être versée
par la ctn et certaines associations
sont mises en difficulté compte tenu du
retard
distel de 2 c'est alors que pendant ce
temps la sécurité sociale leur réclame
effectivement des charges etc et avec
peut-être même menace voyez de saisie
qua non la collectivité tient ses
engagements et ce sont des sommes qui
ont été votées des attributions sont
faites et la collectivité tiendra ses
engagements
d'accord donc lors de ce côté-là voulait
rassurer je pense qu'il faut qu'il soit
que ces associations qu'elles soient
rassurés parce que certains disent être
en grande difficulté à cause de 16 à
l'ours
il faut aussi à mon avis et au voir
globalement et la logique économique
d'un certain nombre d'associations
il n'y a pas que les problèmes de
subversion des subventions sont
nécessaires l'état je sens la
collectivité au sol
mais je pense aussi qu'il est important
que les associations qui sont dans ce
secteur on voit un peu aussi le au
modèle économique alors une citoyenne
martiniquaise m'a appelé tout à l'heure
et m'a dit mais bon vous allez recevoir
francis carole demandez lui si ça peut
aider les personnes quand on supprime
les allocations du rsa alors que ces
personnes là sont vus de réinsertion
mais c'est pas non c'est pas évident
alors voilà il ya une gestion du
du rsa qui est est sous la
responsabilité de la collectivité et
aussi de la caf
nous ce qu'on peut faire parce que nous
y avons été nous faisons en sorte que
l'on ouvre des doigts aux gens d'être
que lorsque quelques temps difficulté
est que cette personne du rsa évidemment
il n'y a aucune volonté de supprimer le
rsa lorsqu'il ya par contre des est
démarqué qui se plaignent de ce qu'elles
considèrent à juste titre ou bien et de
façon erronée comme une injustice
nous analysons des cas et disposition
des données les réponses les plus
rapides donc il n'ya pas de volonté et
de bris mais ceux qui sont les plus en
difficulté pas du tout mais il peut y
avoir surtout quand ils sont en phase de
décision sont le contraire lorsque nous
sommes arrivés aux affaires nous avons
tout fait pour essayer de d'accélérer de
renforcer et de consolider les
sélections de jeunes à travers par
exemple des des initiatives que nous
avons prises à tous inclusion et nous
avons aussi mis en place un projet
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi de mille
bénéficiaires de rsa
au contraire nous avons une politique
très active pour l'insertion pour 6
carroll s'est tenue
ben pas plus tard qu'avant-hier le
conseil territorial de la citoyenneté de
l'autonomie et notamment vous avez
présenté un plan régional l'insertion
des travailleurs handicapés
vous pouvez nous en dire que le
le concept est au real 2
de la citoyenneté de numéros regroupe en
fait les structures majeures et du
handicap et des personnes âgées
alors ce n'est pas notre place le plat
de fête et enfin ce sont des plans qui
doit passer et dans les plénières du
site et ca pour analyse pour avis ça ce
que nous avons fait deux arrêts le plan
régional oui ça s'appelle aux régionales
dans le sens de et territoriales comme
c'est pas le plein de la collectivité
mais c'est le plan pour aller chez le
toiletteur jacques lamarre au clic et
que nous avons analysés et sur lequel
nous avons eu un débat parce que je
pense qu'il faut mettre en relation et
toutes les initiatives qui sont prises
parce qu'il manque justement de liens de
lien entre tout ce qui se fait et le ctc
a c'est vraiment l'endroit où le peut
créer ses clients et qu'est-ce qui le
contient deux majeurs ce plan il est
travailleur la porte sur tout ce qui
concerne l'amélioration de la situation
des travailleurs en situation de
handicap d'une part la question du
respect des 6% ce qui n'est pas ce qui
n'est pas fait mais aussi tout
l'accompagnement qui doit y avoir alors
que 60 des personnels auprès que les
employés les uns devrait reprendre sous
peine de pénalités alors il ya des
entreprises qui préfèrent payer des
pénalités plutôt que du point de vue des
travailleurs en situation de handicap
on est dans octobre bleus là c'était
mille participants du 7 au 26 ctm qui
ça y'est s'est saisie de ce qu'on a
appelé pendant longtemps la silver
economy en fait ça veut dire le
développement la croissance économique
autour du vieillissement de la société
on disait il ya quelques années que ça
présenterait de formidables opportunités
pendant l'impression que ça
le soufflé retombe un peu là non c'est
plus compliqué que ça il y à la silver
kobe est telle qu'elle peut être décliné
dans des pays riches et puis il ya ces
vers économie telle qu'elle peut être
que décliner et dans un pays où la
majorité des bénéficiaires des
bénéficiaires de l'aide sociale sont en
très grande difficulté parce que c'est
il faut prendre cela en considération
nous avons considéré en tout cas que la
question du vieillissement était une
question centrale et dès 2016 nous avons
lancé l'élaboration du schéma de
l'autonomie des personnes âgées des
personnes en situation de handicap
nous avons désormais ce schéma nous
lançons des appels à projets et nous
irons de renforcer l'accompagnement des
personnes âgées les personnes en
situation de handicap parce que la
martinique a pris trop de retard je
n'accuse personne mais il ya eu trop de
retard pris allez on va passer à un
aspect un peu plus politicien maintenant
avec vous francis carole puisque vous
êtes quand même conseiller territorial
exécutif il y a quelques jours on a vu
votre majorité
avoir un petit peu de dissensions est ce
qu'elle est fragilisé notamment au cours
de cette plénière où il y avait deux
positions différentes entre le président
du conseil exécutif alfred marie-jeanne
et le président de l'assemblée qui
présida d'ailleurs là la plénière et
donc il s'agissait de faire entendre une
délégation syndicale ou des délégations
syndicales l'intersyndicale qu'est ce
qui se passe là au sein de la sécurité
je vous délivre à l'elysée quand même
avec des joueurs très simple grille et
il faut parfois regarder ce qui se passe
autour de soi est content et c'est grâce
aux garder ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
au sein du gouvernement français et
ministre de l'intérieur
taddeo chargée de la sécurité des
personnes démissionne en dépit des de la
volonté de président de logar de nos
sens parce nous ne sommes pas à cette
situation là bien entendu c'est une
majorité plurielle
il y à des débats de cette majorité
plurielle mais en même temps je pense
qu'il faut sortir de l'appauvrissement
intellectuelle du débat politique
martinique il faut sortir d'une forme
pardonnez le néologisme
d'une forme de démagogie dation de la
vie politique parce que qu'est ce qui se
passe la ligne de démarcation entre les
démocrates et ceux qui ne sont pas ce
n'est pas de permettre ou non à
d'escargots de près de parler dans une
plénière c'est pas ça qui fait qu'on est
démocrate n'a pas de sens mais
diablement je pense pas aux autres qui
faussent actualiser les plénières et
lorsqu'il y à des questions majeures
je prends le cas de ce qui s'est passé
pour l'hôpital et bien que l'on puisse
donner la parole aux gens mais on a eu
parfois cinq ou six organisations qui
sur des questions particulières
demandées à était revenu à venir donc
c'est plus sur la forme que sur le fond
je pense que je pense que sur le fond il
faut qu'on s'entende il faut qu'il y ait
un matériau et qu'on dise dans quelles
conditions hausse mois on ne reçoit pas
mais on n'est pas il ya des démagos qui
peuvent souhaiter que le que les gens
parlent et donc c'est passé par
seulement une question de ses pendants
la démocratie passe à la question de la
démocratie à la vacation de la
démocratie c'est faire fonctionner
correctement le dialogue social c'est ça
la question
alors vous qui êtes en charge des
affaires sociales cette cette délégation
intersyndicale assistait parce que ça
fait plusieurs jours qu'elles demandent
une entrevue au président du conseil
exécutif alfred marie-jeanne sans
réponse d'une manière générale chaque
fois qu'il y a d'une manière générale
chaque fois qu'il ya des préavis de
grève alors qu'ils sont en grève un
russe donne à chaque fois qu'elle ait
des préavis de desvres nous recevons
parfois sept jours soit souvent j'ai
encore vendredi dernier ont reçu une
délégation de la cgt sur une question
qui concernait
le foie était étoiles de l'enfance dont
qu'on dise que tu j'ai cette semaine un
préavis de grève jeu est discuté à
vienne et l'important c'est d'aimer
traquer les françaises carole et celles
à venir au quotidien de ces personnes en
même temps nicaise et martinique il faut
savoir démêler les fils de cette affaire
nous avons nous avions 200 tentes
contractuels le président du conseil
exécutif à faire en sorte que les 53 de
plus qu'il soit après tant de caunes
savons 290 personnes désormais d'autre
part on parle souvent des gens qui sont
soutenus par les syndicats et a raison
je n'ai rien contre les syndicats mais
qu'est-ce qui défend ceux qui n'ont
jamais trouvé une journée de travail et
qui sont laissés pour compte le
président du conseil exécutif a voulu
faire en sorte que ces gens là aussi
puissent bénéficier de la possibilité
d'avoir accès mais c'est pas un critère
politique c'est pas parce qu'ils se
faisait ils ont été rejoints par les
csss et c'est ça le problème qu'ils ont
été on a quand même qu'ils ont payé
finalement je pense que c'est ce qui est
à l' origine leur compte rendu difficile
le dialogue lorsque cédé qu'à monte au
créneau et déclare que ce sont des
personnes qui ont été employés par
l'ancien président de région qui a été
et ce en interne qui n'a pas été
renouvelé mais c'est faux parce qu'il ya
aussi des gens de 2016 2017 qui ont été
recrutés pendant que maryse on était là
donc mais un contrat c'est un contrat ce
sont des contrats à durée déterminée
alors bien entendu est un aspect qui est
un aspect de d'humanité et plus de
compréhension des difficultés
donc on essaie d'accompagner au mieux
possible il doit y avoir d
accompagnement social
on ne peut pas de mépris pour les
souffrances qui existe mais on ne peut
pas non plus se servir de ça comme un
élément de démagogie pour essayer de
déstabiliser la la collectivité il y à
de vraies revendications des
travailleurs de la saison et il faudra
prendre en compte il faut discuter mais
en même temps il ne faut pas exclu
maternisé chaque situation
pendant que celui qui donne des ordres
dit qu'il faut une revanche populaire au
met tout en oeuvre pour garder ce qui se
passe en guadeloupe a terminé il est
7h30 et 9h accepté sa défaite et bien ce
n'est pas le cas de l'ancien président
de région qui essaient d'attiser la
haine à marseille merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ça passe très vite
française carole vann bonne journée à
toutes ces recherches